خطاب للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بمناسبه
مرور عام على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
من كل ارجاء البلاد شكرا جزيلا لكم لترحب
بكم مره اخرى الى بولندا مره عام تقريبا
كل عام تقريبا موضوع تحدثت في هذه القلعه
بعد ان
شنى الرئيس بوتين عدوانه الدموي على
اوكرانيا
هذه المبادئ التي
ارسلت الامن والاستقرار على كوكبنا لاكثر
من 75 عاما عرضه
لتحطيم منذ عام العالم
كان يدعو من اجل ان تصمد وانا جئت الى
واقول انك صامده وقويه
منتصبه القامه والاهم انها حره
عندما غازت روسيا لم تكن اوكرانيا هي التي
تعرضت للاختبار بل العالم باسره اختبر
اختبر اختبارا على ماذا اجيال انتم
اختبرتم الولايات المتحده اختبرتو
ايضا كل الامم الحره السؤال الذي يواجهنا
هو سؤال سهل ولكنه
راسخ هل نرد اما نشيح انظارنا هل
علينا ان نكون متوحدين جميع الحلفاء هل
نتحد ام نتفرق بعد عام من ذلك العدوان
وصلنا الى
الجواب سنكون اقوياء وسنكون متحدين
والعالم لن يتجاهل ما يحدث
ايضا نحن نواجهه مساله
جذريه تهدد مبادئنا الاساسيه هل نقف
مدافعيننا سياده الدول وحق الناس بالعيش
بحريه ضد العدوان هل نقفوه
داعمين للديمقراطيه بعد ما نحن نعرف الان
الاجابه نعم سنقف ونؤيد السياده وفعلنا
ذلك
سنؤيد حق الناس بالعيش بحريه وسندافع عن
الديمقراطيه وهكذا فعلنا وامس تشرفت
بالوقوف الى جانب اريز اللينسكي في كييف
لاعلن اننا سنواصل دفاعا عن هذه القضايا
وعن هذه المبادئ مهما حصل
عندما امر الرئيس بوتين دباباته
بالسياحه كان يعتقد باننا سنستسلم وسنقف
مكتوفين الايدي لكنه كان مخطئا لم يعرف
مدى صمود وشجاعه
الشعب الاوكراني ووحده صف النيتو العالم
الديمقراطيه كانت قويه وعصيه لم تمكنه من
تحقيق الانتصار السائل الذي كان يعتقده
دباباته احترقت
ارتاله توقفت كان يعتقد انه النبي بامكانه
ان يمزق
ولكنه وحد النيتو كان يعتقد انه سيستخدم
سياسه فرق تسودا ويفرق
وحلف الاطلسي ولكن الحلف هو اقوى واكثر
وحده من اي وقت مضى كان باعتقاده ان
يستخدم الطاقه كسر الى ليكسر
بدنا اكثر اعتماد اكثر واستقلاليه عن
موارد الطاقه الروسيه كان يعتقد انه قوي
وان قاده الديمقراطيه هم ناعمون وضعفاء
ولكنه لم يعرف اننا لن نقبل عالما تحكمه
القوه وجد نفسه في حرب مع بلد يقوده شخص
يتحلى بشجاعه والجراه وعزيمته اصلب من
الفولاذ الرئيس زيلينسكي نعم الرئيس بوتين
واجه امرا لم يكن لم يكن يعتقده
صحيحا قبل عام ولكن الديمقراطيه باتت اقوى
وليست اضعف والحكام الاطقراطيون هم من
اصبحوا ضعفاء وليس اقوياء
بسبب وفي اوقات عدم اليقين لا يعرفه ان
ان من يقف معك هو الذي يحدث الفرق الحقيقي
الشعب البولندي يعرفون ذلك انتم تعرفون
ذلك وتعرفون ربما اكثر من اي شخص اخر في
بولندا لانها لان هذا ما يعنيه التضامن
عندما
دمرت
العاصمه بعد عقود من الحكم الشيوعي صمدت
بولندا لانكم وقفتم متحدين
وهكذا
ما زال المواطنين الاحرار في روسيا
البيضاء يدافعون عنه
ديمقراطيهم وكذلك الاحرار في مولدوفا
صمودو الشعب الملتهوى وتطلعهم للعيش في
ديمقراطيه
عندما حصلوا على استقلالهم وقدموا طلبا
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الرئيس
سانتو موجود معنا موجود معنا لا ادري اين
هي ولكنني افخر بالوقوف مع الشعب
المولدوبي هي تستحق فعلا التحيه والتصفيق
عامل من بدء هذه الحرب الرئيس بوتين لم
يعد يشككوا في قوتنا ووحدتنا ولكنه ربما
يشكك فيه
اعتقادنا وصمودنا ربما يشكك في دعمنا
لاوكرانيا ربما مازال يشكك في ان النيتو
سيبقى يدا واحده ولكن ينبغي ان لا يكون
لديكم شك بان دعمنا لاوكرانيا لن يتزعزع
وسيبقى راسخا واننا لن نستسلم الرئيس
بوتين
وسيفشل في تعطشه للقوه وللدماء ومن سيفوز
في نهايه المطاف هو الشعب الاوكراني
الديمقراطيه هي حاميه الحريه الامس واليوم
وغدا
اذا هذا هو هذا ما هو على الرهان الان وما
هو على المحاكي الحريه وهي الرساله التي
حملتها حملتها معي الى كييف
نطقت بها للشعب الاوكراني وقال رئيس ان
هذا النضال يحدد العالم وما الذي سيعيشك
وكيف سيعيش ابنائنا واحفادنا وابنائهم
واحفادهم هو لم يكن يتحدث عن الابناء
والاحفاد الاوكرانيين بل كان يتحدث عن كل
ابنائنا واحفادنا ابنائكم ابنائكم
وابناؤنا وهذا ما نراه اليوم في الشعب
البولندي وهذا الشعب الذي صمد لعقود
لا يمكن ان نرضي الحكام المستبدين بل
ينبغي ان نعارضهم هم لا يفهمون سوى كلمه
واحده وهي لا لا وكلا ولا نعم لن تستطيعوا
احتلال بلدي ولن تنزعوا مني حريتي ولن
تنزعوا مني مستقبلي وانا اكرر ما قلته
العام الماضي في ذات المكان والزمان
الذي يتطلع لبناء امبراطوريه لا يمكن ان
يحرم الناس من الحريه والوحشيه لا يمكن ان
تقمع الاحرار واوكرانيا
لن تكون ان تمثل انتصارا لروسيا ابدا
نحن شعب حر ونرفض ان نعيش في عالم يسوده
الظلام
والعتمه كان عاما مذهلا بكل معنى الكلمه
وحشيه استثنائيه من قبل قواتي الروسيه
والمرتزقه وما زالوا ناظمونها في وحشيتهم
جرائم حرب دون خجل هم يستهدفون المدنيين
بالموت والدمار
يستخدمون الاغتصاب كسلاح حرب
يسرقون الاطفال الاوكرانيين
محاورين سرقه مستقبل اوكرانيا يقصفون
محطات القطار والمستشفيات المدارس
وغيرها لا احد يمكن ان يشيح بنظره عن
المذابح البشعه التي ارتكبتها روسيا بحق
الشعب الاوكراني فهذا فظيع فظيع للغايه
ولكن
المذهل والاستثنائي هو رده فعل الشعب
الاوكراني وردته فعل العالم بعد عام من
بدء القصف وسقوط القنابل
الدبابات الروسيه اجتاحت اوكرانيا ولكن
اوكرانيا ما زالت دوله مستقله وحره
[تصفيق]
الاوكرانيون السعاده وارضهم او خمسين
بالمئه او خمسين بالمئه من الاراضي التي
احتلتها روسيا
وعلم الاوكراني
يرفرفوا فخورا
والحكومه التي تمثل الشعب الامريكي الشعب
الاوكراني عفوا
والعالم ممثلا بالجميع العامه اليوم
المتحده ادان العدوان الروسي وايد ودعم
السلام العالم في شهر اكتوبر 143 دوله
اعضاء في الامم المتحده اذان الضم غير
القانوني اربع دول فقط
صوتت الى جانب روسيا
انا اخاطب الشعب الروسي مره اخرى واقول ان
الولايات المتحده والدول الاوروبيه لا
تسعى الى احتلال روسيا او تدميره نحن لا
نتطلع الى الهجوم على روسيا كما قال بوتين
اليوم الملايين من المواطنين الروس فقط
يريدون العيش بسلام الى جانب جيرانهم وليس
وليس كاعداء الحرب ليست ضروره بل هي ماساه
رئيس بوتين اختار الحرب
في كل يومين تستمر فيه الحرب هذا يتم
باختيار بامكانه ان ينهي هذه الحرب
ويوقفها ويوقفها بكلمه واحده الامر سهل
وبسيط اذا ما توقفت روسيا
غزوها لاوكرانيا فستتوقف الحرب واذا ما
اوقفت عدوانها فستتوقف الحرب وبالتالي
علينا ان نضمن
ونتاكد من قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
نفسها والولايات المتحده
والحلف الدولي الذي يضم اكثر من خمسين
بلدا قدم الاسلحه والمعدات والامدادات
للاوكرانيين في الخطوط الاماميه انظمه
دفاع جوي مدفعيه ذخائر صواريخ
والاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك والولايات المتحده
التزمت بشكل غير مسبوق تجاه الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا من خلال تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه وكذلك مساعدات الاقتصاديه
والانسانيه وغيرها الكثير وكل ولكل
الحاضرين هنا اقول
انظروا في وجوه بعضكم بعض تاملوا فيما
حققتموه الى الان بولندا تستضيف اكثر من
مليون ونصف اللاجئ فروا من جحيم هذه الحرب
بارككم الرب
كرمكم وسخائكم هو امر استثنائي وقد فتحته
عن بيوتكم
للاجئين والولايات المتحده معكم في هذه
الجهود في كل انحاء بلدي
المدن الكبرى والبلدات الصغيره الرايات
والاعلام الاوكرانيه ترفرف وتلوحوا فقط كل
المنازل الامريكيه الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون في الكونغرس وقفوا معا صفا
واحدا دفاعا عن الحريه هذا هو صميم
الامريكيين وهذا هو جمهور جوهر الامريكيين
وهذا ما يقوم به الامريكيين دائما
نحن ايضا سنتوحد ضد تداعيات وتبعاتي هذه
الحرب التي شنها بوتين بوتين يحاول ان
يدمر العالم
في اوقف
اوقف سفن الشحن في البحر الاسود يحاول ان
يمنع اوكرانيا من تصدير
محاصيلها الغذائيه وهذا ما ضرب دول كثيره
في الصميم
الولايات المتحده والدول السبعه الكبرى
وشركائها في العالم لبوا النداء وتصدوا
لهذه الازمه من اجل
من اجل وقفي تداعيتي الازمه الغذاء وزوجتي
ستسافر لتسليط الضبط الضوء على هذا
الموضوع التزامنا تجاه الشعب الاوكراني
ومستقبل اوكرانيا اوكرانيا حره ذات سياده
وديمقراطيه
من
اعلنوا استقلال اوكرانيا قبل 30 عاما ومن
قادوا ثوره الكرامه ثوره البرتقاليه ومن
الذين خرجوا الى بدران والمئات الذين لقوا
حتفهم في الاحتجاجات والذين بقوا
يواجهون
بوتين اذا هذا حلم الوطنيين الاوكرانيين
الذين حاربوا لسنوات ضد العدوان الروسي في
منطقه
الذين ضحوا بكل شيء ضحوا بحياتهم خدمه
لبلدهم الحبيب اوكرانيا انا تشرفت بزياره
النصب التذكاري في كييفا الذي تم
نصبه تقليدا لذكرى
تقليدا لذكرها هؤلاء الذين دافعوا عن
بلدهم
الاطباء والمعلمون ومستجيبون الاوائل
والعمال الذين
يناظرون من اجله ابقاء الطاقه الكهربائيه
ضد
نحن نقف الى جانب ملايين اللاجئين الذين
نزحوا عن بلدهم ووجدوا ووجدوا ملجا في
اوروبا وفي الولايات المتحده وتحديدا هنا
في بولندا
الملايين من الاوروبينا هبو
لدعم هؤلاء
السيده الاولى البولنديه
برهنت عن حقيقه وجوهر الروح الانسانيه
السيده الاولى نحن نحب ويكي نحبك جميعنا
[تصفيق]
لن انسى
عندما التقيت بلاجئين
اوكرانيا وصلوا الى وارسو وجوههم شاحبه
متعبون كانوا يعتقدون بانهم لن يروا
ابائهم وامهاتهم وازواجهم وزوجاتهم في تلك
الاوقات الحالكه انتم الشعب الاوكراني من
وفرتهم لهم الامن والامان والحياه انتم من
احتضنت
احتضنتموهم فعلا وكنت اشاهد تعابير وجوههم
انذاك وفي هذه الاثناء علينا ان نضمن بان
تدفع روسيا ثمنا باهظا جراء عدوانها
وسنواصل فرضا اسرى نظام عقوبات يفرضوا في
التاريخ وسنععلن عن المزيد من العقوبات
هذا الاسبوع بمعيه شركائنا وسنحاسب اولئك
المسؤولون عن مسؤولين عن تلك الحرب
سنحقق العداله
الجرائم التي ارتكبها الروس هنالك الكثير
مما يدعون الى الفخر وما حققناه معا منذ
العام الماضي ولكن علينا ان نكون امنا
وصادقين ونحن تطلعوا الى الايام القادمه
الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه ليس عمل يوم او عام
فهذا امر صعب وعصيب امر
وفي الوقت الذي تواصل فيه اوكرانيا الدفاع
عن نفسها ضد
العدوان الروسي وتشنه هجمات مضاده ضد
الروس سيكون هناك ايام صعبه وعصيبه نعم
سيكون هنالك انتصارات وماس ولكن ستواصل
اوكرانيا حربها
والولايات المتحده والوحلفاء وشراكه
سيقفون الى جانب اوكرانيا في دفاعها عن
نفسها العام القادم ساستضيف كل اعضاء دول
النيتو في قمه الحلف لعام 2024 في واشنطن
معا
بمروري 75 عاما على انشائي اقوى حلف
دفاعيا في العالم وهو حلف شمال الاطلسي او
حلف النيتو
ولتكونوا على يقين بان التزام الولايات
المتحده تجاهها الحلف وخاصه المدى الخامسه
من ميثاق هي راسخه وقويه وكل
عضوا يعرفون ذلك وروسيا تعرف ذلك انه
الهجوم ضد اي دوله عضو يعد هجوما على جميع
الدول الاعضاء فهذا قسم مقدس لانه دافع عن
كل شبر من اراضي النيتو خلال العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده اتحدت مع حلفائها
وشركائها في تحالف استثنائي للوقوف ضد
العدوان الروسي ولكن العمل ما زال
امامنا هذا علينا ان نحدد العالم الذي
نريد ان نبني علينا ان نعزز قوه
نعمل على تحسين حياه الناس من القاعده الى
الاعلى ان نوفر الرخاء نبني السلامه
والاستقرار نعامل الجميع بالاحترام اذا
هذه هي المسؤوليه الملقاه على عاتقنا
الديمقراطي الديمقراطيه العالم يجب ان
تخدم الناس
والعالم من وجهه نظري يواجه لحظه فارقه
والقرارات التي سنتخذها خلال الخمس سنوات
الماضيه ستحدد وتشكل حياتنا لعقود قادمه
هذا صحيح بالنسبه لامريكا وبالنسبه لباقي
شعوب العالم
والقرارات التي نتخذها الان والمبادئ التي
هي على المحك هي ابديه الخيار بين الفوضى
والاستقرار بين البناء والدمار بين الام
والخوف بين الديمقراطيه التي ترفع روح
البشريه
واليد القبضه الحديديه الوحشيه
ما بين توفير الفرص بلا حدود
الفرص
تتحقق عندما يعيش الناس ليس في الحبس
والقيود بل في ظل الحريه الحريه النبيله
ما من
ما من هدف اعلى من الحريه الامريكيون
يعرفون ذلك وانتم تعرفون ذلك كل ما نقوم
به الان ينبغي ان يفعل من اجل خدمه
ابنائنا واحفادنا الذي يعرفون حق المعرفه
بان الحريه هي عدو الاستبداد والطغيان وهي
امل الاجيال القادمه الحريه يقفوا معنا
والى سنقف الى جانبكم لنمضي بالايمان
والاعتقاد والتزام بايدن بان نبقى
حلفاء في النور وليس في الظلام وليس وفي
ليس في ظروف القمع والاضطهاد بله بالحريه
فليبارك بكم الرب جميعا
ويحمي الرب
قواتنا مسلحه ويحمي الابطال الاوكرانيه
والكل من يدافع عن الحريه في كل انحاء
العالم شكرا لكم بولندا وشكرا لكم ايها
البولنديين شكرا شكرا شكرا
فيكم جميعا
[تصفيق]